there is the singularity in the center
so
inside the event horizon we know that
all the matter collects
at a point now we can't
really predict what happens at the
singularity because
einstein's theory breaks down and we
know why it breaks down because it
doesn't have
quantum mechanics that talks about small
distances
we don't have a theory that unifies
quantum mechanics and gravity
so that it will predict what happens in
near a singularity
and in fact you know i once um a couple
of years ago i had
a flood the in my basement i mean
and i invited the plumber to come over
and
and figure out and we found that the
sewer was
clogged because of three
routes that got into it and we solved
the problem
but then i i thought to myself
well isn't that what happens to the
singularity of a black hole because
the question is where does the matter go
you know if you know in the case of
a home i never thought about it but the
water all the water that we use
goes in you know through the sewer to
some reservoir somewhere
and the question is what happens inside
a black hole and
one possibility is that there is an
object in the middle just like a star
you know and everything collects there
and the object has the maximum density
that we can imagine like
planck densities it's the ultimate
density that you can have
where gravity is as strong as all the
other forces
so you can imagine this object very
dense object at the center that collects
all the matter
another possibility is that there is
some tunnel just like the sewer it takes
the matter into another place
and we don't know the answer but i wrote
a scientific american essay about it and
uh admitting my our ignorance it's a
fascinating question what happens to the
method that goes into black hole
i actually recommend it to some of my
colleagues that work on string theory
i at the closing of a conference i'm the
founding director
of the black hole initiative at harvard
which brings together astronomers
physicists philosophers and
mathematicians
and we have a conference once a year and
at the end of one of them
since i'm the director i had to
summarize and i said
that i wish we could go on a field trip
to a black hole nearby
and i highly recommend to my colleagues
that work on string theory
to enter into that black hole because
then they can test their theory
when they get inside but one of the
string theorists in the audience nimar
khani hamad
immediately raised his voice and said
you have an ulterior motive for sending
us into a black hole
which i didn't deny but
you